الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا والبدايه
بالتطورات الميدانيه اذ اعلن حاكم شبه
جزيره القرم الروسي ما اختلفتات بهجوم
اوكراني بالمسيرات على بلده شمال غربي شبه
الجزيره في المقابل قالت السلطات المحليه
في ميكولايف واوديسا جنوبي اوكرانيا ان
احد عشر شخصا اصيب في قصف روسي وعقبا
اعلان روسيا تعليق العمل باتفاق تصدير
الحبوب قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
المياه الواقعه جنوب شرقي وجنوب غربي
البحر الاسود اعلنت مؤقتا مناطق خطيره
للملاحه في المقابل قناه السلطات
الاوكرانيه انها ستعتبر السفن المتجهه الى
روسيا في البحر الاسود سفن عسكريه محتمله
للمتابعه انضموا الينا من دنيتك من درغامي
ومن كيف عمر الحاج وابدا معك عمر من هذا
الموقف الاوكراني حول السفن في البحر
الاسود
نعم محمود يبدو ان كييف لم تجد ملتحدا او
بدا من التعامل بالمثل مع تهديد الروسي
الذي توعد كل السفن التي ستجرب الاستمرار
بعمل بالعمل باتفاقيه الحبوب بشكل منفرد
مع اوكرانيا بانها ستكون اهدافا مشروعه
للبحريه الروسيه في هذا البيان تقول بشكل
حازم ان اوكرانيا ايضا ستتعامل مع كل
السفن التي تتوجه الى الموانئ الروسيه في
البحر الاسود او الموانئ الاوكرانيه التي
تقع تحت سيطره القوات الروسيه في البحر
الاسود بالمثل وانها ستعتبرها تحمل مواد
عسكريه او تجهيزات عسكريه لروسيا وبالتالي
ستكون هدفا مشروعا لاوكرانيا ايضا
البيان ايضا اجاب عن التساؤل ربما قد يطرح
عن مدى امكانيه اوكرانيا القيام بهذا
العمل وان كانت لديها القدرات الحقيقيه
لفرض نوع من الحظر على الملاحه باتجاه
الموالي الروسيه كان البيان نتحدث عن
تذكير بمصير الطراد موسكو الذي
دمرته البحريه الاوكرانيه في شهر نيسان من
العام الماضي وقالت انها قادره على
استهداف هذه السفن وانها مجهزه بكل
الامكانات التي تمكنها من فرض مثل هذا
الحظر ايضا في البيان كان هناك موعد محدد
وهو منتصف الليل من يومه 21 من الشهر
الحالي الموعد النهائي لتحرك هذه السفن
كما قالت بحريه باتجاه الموانئ الروسيه
وذلك كما ذكرنا مره اخرى ردا على البيان
الروسي الذي توعد السفن التي تتجه الى
الموانئ الاوكرانيه ايضا في بيانات اليوم
كان هناك تمديد روسي تهديد اوكراني بما
قامت به روسيا خلال الايام الماضيه من
استهداف لموانئ البنيه التحتيه ام الموانئ
والبنيه التحتيه في اوكرانيا تحدثت
تحدثكي عن وقوع خسائر وضحايا في هذا
الاستهداف خاصه في كل من
ايديسا وايضا ميكولايف وتحدث عن تعمد
روسيا استهدافه المناطق الموانئ التي تخزن
كميات من القمح التي كانت من ان تذهب الى
دول في افريقيا والى اسيا وقال ان روسيا
بهذا تتعمدوا ربما ايجاده نوعا من التجويع
او ازمه غذاء عالميه في هذه المناطق عبر
هذا الاستهداف عمر شكرا لك ابقى معنا نشير
الى الخبر العاجل الذي تبعناه على الشاشه
باعلاني وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه فرض
حزمه عقوبات جديده تستهدف شخصيات الوكيلات
روسيه اتحول الى
امين درغامي من دنيتك امين اطلعنا على اخر
التطورات
محمود يبدو ان منطقه البحر الاسود وحول
شبه جزيره القرمبات الان ساحه
المعارك بين البلدين اي بين روسيا
واوكرانيا باستخدام طبعا الطائرات المسيره
وايضا القوارب
والصواريخ روسيا اعلنت اليوم على انها
نفذت الليله الماضيه هجوما وصفته
بالانتقامي على اهداف في كل من اوديسا
وايلي تشيفز في البحر الاسود اضافه الى
اهداف اخرى في المقاطعه المجاوره قالت بان
هذه الاهداف هي عباره عن ورش لتصنيع
القوارب المسيره وايضا تخزينها اضافه الى
مخازن للذخيره التابعه للجيش الاوكراني
وايضا الوقود الذي يستخدم لاغراض عسكريه
روسيا بذلك يكون موقفها بانها لم يعد عن
لم يعد امامها اي
عائق قانوني من يعني يمنعها من استهداف
طبعا لليوم الثالث على توالي الترد مثل
هذه الانباء عن التقدم الروسي وجاءت ايضا
هذه الانباء عن التقدم الروسي بعد ان كانت
هناك معلومات تفيد بان الجيش الروسي دفع
بتعزيزات اضافيه الى ذلك المحور اضافه الى
محور لا يبعد عنه كثيرا وهو محور لمان
بمقاطعه دونياتك او على الحدود بين لوغان
سكوات في باخموت يبدو ان الاوضاع يعني ما
زالت محتدمه هناك معارك متواصله وتاكيد من
قبل الجانب الروسي على انه يصد هجمات
اوكرانيه خاصه في اتجاه بلده كليشيفك التي
تقع الى جنوب من مدينه بخنوت هنا في دونيس
اصوات المدفعيه الثقيله محمود تدوي منذ
صباح اليوم فيما يبدو انه قصف متبادل بين
الجانبين السلطات هنا في دنياس المواليه
لروسيا قالت بان احياء في شمال وفي غرب
المدينه تعرضت من جديد لقصف اوكراني دون
ان تعلن عن سقوط او وقوع خسائر بشريه امين
درغام من دنيتك وعمر الحاج من كيف شكرا
جزيلا لكما